[Musica]
i ragazzi e prendere questo video sono
vari geni e tages chiosa the world race
ce la farò mai a dirlo giusta la prima
volta le world hardesty game tre ragazzi
siccome l'ho iniziato il 2 non avevo
finito ma non ce la farò mai più ad
arrivare come cazzola arrivato perché è
impossibile ha deciso di iniziare altre
perché almeno in questo cerco di fare un
punteggio decente si svela menu casi
cliccasse porcaccia vacca no perché non
è possibile che non si riesce neanche a
partire è già impossibile dire no non ci
credo
no chiasso per andare su nuova partita
devo andarci non appena questa è una
figata
giuro su quello che volete che non avevo
capito ci siamo ragazzi prova non so che
cosa sto per incontrare ma va bene così
ok una navigata e regala della
federazione allora questo mi sembra
facile no perché siamo questo contate
che il primo non so che a cazzo può
accadere dopo infatti non è una cosa
così possibile
minchia semi salvavo se non solo il
primo è questa qui è bellissima ok
adesso domanda volte devo prendere le
cose andare alla fine perfetto non è
impossibile dai si può fare si può fare
si può fare si può fare minchia che cosa
ho fatto o che kami lega cambia gas
no no no no no no no carissimi che
quando posso ok che porta di cura del
vado non è finita non lo sapevo cosa
adesso ci sono i sotto livelli dei
livelli fantastico e devo fare ma
l'altra quasi nulli
le ma non riuscirei mai a di farlo devo
arrivare ma questi sono check point si
sono check point grazie a dio ed è
troppo difficile sta cosa però si può
fare mi sto cosa faccio tipo questo
troppa roba così
roba in mezzo ancora non ho capito sono
smoccolato cosa ok pole pole è perfetto
che cos'è quella porta d'oro non lo so
ma non lo voglio neanche scoprire
sinceramente devo merda ok perfetto a ok
sia prestata porta perfetto c'è una
parte gole due porte perfetto adesso
torni indietro
minchia che ora mi si sta incrociando il
cervello e adesso domanda
ok ok sto schifo se prima era difficile
adesso ancora peggio perché ci sono i
sottolivelli è impossibile no ok ok no
no porca l'adrano attimo che la cosa si
fa a fare sta parte si vuole ecco
perfetto di arrivare insieme un
possibile regalo fare tipo un giro
assurdo madonna cosa ho fatto è stato
assurdo e adesso mi incazzo proprio mia
nonna scriverebbe meglio ma [ __ ]
ammazzo amico mio tu devi capire che
senza di me non sei un cazzo quindi
evita di farti se battute perché non sei
nessuno
vediamo di capirci un attimo perché è
assurdo che non riesca a fare questa
parte non è possibile
eccolo lì perfetto adesso ci devono ok
perché sono riuscito ad essere
impossibile mi sono appena aperto la
strada verso l'alto
advent reining sei ancora provando zio
sono stai zitto tifi lo so io dove ma
l'avevo aperta la porta perché il cazzo
succede morisse la sorella non è
possibile reagan no vabbè dai tutor non
lo posso di fare c'è un suicidio e
invece no e invece no madonna cosa ha
fatto a caso a caso
ok adesso si è riaperta non devo morire
in pratica impossibile farlo senza
morire non si può fare le gambe come
cazzo faccia un umori
si vabbè ho capito ma camorra
il mio nome fa vigente stadi culo ok
guardalo marche culo che culo ok non
fate domande non so cosa stavo morendo
adesso ho preso sta cosa sono diventato
verde fantastico ma niente ci ho messo
40 minuti per trasformarmi in un pezzo
di vomito fantastico tra e bellavista
giocati funky incazzare anche cos'è sto
schifo
no grazie alla dai seriamente sta cosa
sporca
no no no no no no ma donna cominciò la
fermi un secondo che allora devo capire
un attimo se no non è forse non si può
fare place mag stop mi hai rotto le
palle per mezz'ora quindi evita di
lamentarti adesso lo devo capire ok ok
troppa roba troppa demenza come ho fatto
a far sbagliare alla fine
mortacci sua no si ok non basta né
possibile che sbaglia allora calmi piano
piano
ok adesso con questa mi manca l'ultima
che non ci arriverò mai ma sono dettagli
come faccio arrivare
ok ok calami un attimo bene bene olè che
culo ma anche a pochissimo ma ci siamo
regalati
si ok tanta roba agio
s'è aperta ragazzi aperta la porta
perfetto da me ne sbatto le palle della
chiave me ne vado giù stima di 20
ragazzi la chiave era per aprire il
vomito cioè non serve a niente altri
poche parole serve soltanto a
quell'altro che l'ho già presa inutile
che continuo torni indietro ci siamo
eccolo che arriva rega preparatevi ci
arriva il tipo gomito zoe eccolo qui
perfetto 92 cazzo di morti ieri che cosa
ti esulti vuoi cambiare il mio colore
nel menu ogni volta che vuoi colleziona
tutti i sei colori collezione mi sta
minkia continuo vediamo che perfetto
questo non è ancora tanto difficile
avverte per favore alla stiamo a livello
dopo 80 minuti di gioco si esatto colle
madonna cosa ho fatto menzione che sale
pero ce la posso fare ciò posso fare
merda ragazzo fatto non chiedetemi come
in sostanza non ci torno private non me
ne frega un cazzo venpa infattibile con
la roba quindi vado con questa ok
cos'è sta roba mia nonna saprebbe
schivarlo meglio dalla fai così fai
io adesso non gioco più un cazzo chiama
tua nonna e fallo fare a lei evita anche
di morire ma volta che schifo non ideali
con ci sia riuscito si è aperta la porta
a camin attimo che non è impossibile è
impossibile
no no no no possiamo andar avanti così
porca di quella ladra ok ok una sega ok
una sega ragazzi domani mattina siamo
ancora qui
[Musica]
sia lodato il cielo ragazzi non so cosa
ho fatto non me non mi fate domande il
nonno idea sono morte continuerà a
morire non mi prendere per il culo non
ha dovuto recare il coso verde lì non
l'ho toccato da non fottutissimo
deficiente carminati con questo sfogo
cibo le ho preso c'è poi lo riprendo per
sicurezza ma è in forse i ragazzi sta
parte impossibili ve lo dico non ce la
farò mai a questo livello
maremma l'altra ok ok perfetto si fa
fare sta parte adesso ma se mi chiami ci
sono se mi sembra facile ok non una sega
proprio di fa veramente piacere che un
giorno mi abbiate consigliato il suo
gioco qui perché guarda qualcuno è
partita stile a non so da chi è partita
ma io lo troverò e lo ucciderò il prima
possibile peggiora il cazzo se 224 morti
mio dio devo ammazzare qualcuno so
neanche come ho fatto
cos'è questa merda non lo so neanche non
voglio neanche saperlo ninfa basta io ho
fatto questo per me è già ho vinto già
tutto devo trovare la tattica di sta
roba perché è assurdo allora non ce la
farò mai
non è possibile ma non ho mai assurdo no
non si può fare il nome sto rompendo i
[ __ ] bellissime ragazze necessità di
tornare indietro perché era talmente
facile che ho detto non va beh questo è
troppo semplice quindi proviamo altri io
giuro che questo gioco mi fa veramente
incazzare non è una cosa questo mi fa
veramente tanto incazzare cioè non sa
cosa assurda che mi strappo i capelli
una un hotel in filo su per il culo
[Musica]
vuole la pace e la tranquillità ce l'ha
fatta di fare le prossime sfide costa
musichetta qua perché almeno almeno mi
rilassa almeno questo ok già ecco sul
livello già il calmo quindi ci sta a
pennello
no porca [ __ ] nov affanculo 2 la
musichetta rilassante giovanni famiglia
all'italia più di prima si no porca
[ __ ] che culo non lavora anche visto
che è arrivato fin qua meno male non è
infatti via lega non infattibile come
pensavo grande se semi oddio cosa ho
aperto non l'ho visto ho fatto una cosa
pazzesca non fate domando non saprei di
farla per nessun motivo al mondo tipo
vedi che la musica funziona se stesse mi
calmo
se mi calma un attimo feliciano giuro
porca [ __ ] mi sta salendo il crimine
cota ci siamo lo sento lo sento sento si
eccolo ok ce l'abbiamo fatta ragazzi non
so cos'è sta roba facciamo c'è un limite
va bene che sto gioco deve rappresentare
l'impossibile tipo che io ci sono appena
riuscito a non so come ho fatto
cosa offerto ok sono aperte i ragazzi ci
ha pian piano sto facendo non chiedetevi
comico invogliarmi almeno tornare
davvero prima una sega propria vediamo
un attimo se riesco ok ok
sì sì già fatta lega giovanni non so
come ma ce l'ho fatta perché le faccio
una volta le cose non ci riesco più
minchia ok ciò abbiamo fatto ragazzi si
comandano in questo words are the seas
gay ma non si sono degnati di mettere un
tasto continua al vero la prossima volta
che lo continuo ce la faccia senza
rifarlo daccapo e quindi questo possa
effettivamente continuare ok un passo
alla volta piano è già faccio
ok si camera l'america si che culo pure
calcio fatti lo presi io penso a
giocatori a dire che possono includere
che l'episodio visto che c'è il tasto
continua almeno quello che i ragazzi e
le mie 415 morti vi salutiamo e vabbè
lasciamo stare con i ragazzi del video è
piaciuto come sentono sotto commento mi
piace anche a pagina di facebook e come
ogni video provata una descrizione solo
troveresti iscrivetevi noi ci mettiamo
le posizioni dei ragazzi